well as families across the valleys
really struggle to stay afloat a lot of
southern nevadans are
stepping in to help 8 news now reporter
kate houston shows us how one local
woman
turned her living room full of donations
into a full-blown
charity it's probably the single most
fulfilling thing outside of my own
motherhood that i've ever done
tammy dukey founded hope cove in may
after seeing so many families struggle
to feed
and care for their babies a teenage
momma and she had her
little baby with her and her baby was
wearing
hand to god paper towels wrapped in
cling wrap
for a diaper i cried for 20 minutes
after she left
initially dookie used her living room as
a central location
to collect donations from across the
valley what started as a few boxes
soon stacked to the ceiling it
snowballed it just grew and grew and
grew
soon we were bursting out of my house
hope cove has now expanded to its very
own location families are able to come
here for assistance
no questions asked hope cove is
available for all family dynamics
including single dads grandparents and
foster parents
the nonprofit provides immediate
assistance for items such as diapers
formula hygiene products and more there
are no qualifiers or documents needed to
receive help
people coming from homelessness people
who live in weeklies people who live in
motels
people living with family they just
cannot supply those things
so for those people i founded hope code
eventually dookey would like to move
hope cove to a bigger building and have
multiple locations across the valley
something further south i would like to
have something
in the north end just because a lot of
the people that we serve have no
transportation
dukey even has plans to take hope cove
across state lines to help as many
families as possible kate houston 8 news
now
and she's really made an impact hope
cove has helped more than
2 300 families just since may and right
now the nonprofit though is reliant
solely on donations so here's what they
need
diapers sizes three and up along with
baby wipes and they always need formula
to see how you can donate or perhaps
maybe you need help you can head to our
website at 8newsnow.com